philippine boxing icon manny pacquiao
says he's going to run for president in
the 2022 election pacquiao is now a
senator he was nominated by a faction of
the ruling party it comes after a rival
faction named a senator and long-time
aide of president rodrigo duterte as its
choice they also named duterte as their
vice president nominee
we need progress
we need to win against poverty
we need government to serve our people
with integrity
compassion
and transparency
the time is now
we are ready to rise
to the challenge of leadership
crusades is a writer and journalist
based in manila she's joining us from
there good to have you with us on al
jazeera um just for a bit of context how
big are the divisions beneath roberto
duterte
the division in his party you mean
yes how might big are the gaps that are
beginning to appear within his party
well it looks like they can't seem to
decide what to do i mean it a lot of
political observers seem to think that
there is a show going on some kind of a
circus
um he wanted uh his aide to run for
president um more like a proxy
presidential candidate and he runs for
vice president and there's the daughter
who was is running ahead of the polls
but was upset
that the that the aide was going to run
as a vice president and then you also
have manny pacquiao
um who wants to be the president and he
he could probably do it just because
he's a an iphone very popular lots of
money
but if it really comes to real
governance and running democratic
institutions i'm not sure he's his he's
up to that lead
i i want to ask you about manny pacquiao
in in just a second but i mean in russia
we saw president vladimir putin step
aside from the presidency and become
prime minister twice in fact to allow
him to become prime minister president
again
are we seeing something similar here
yes a lot of people are making that
comparison
um
well just to give you a background in
the philippines you're only allowed to
have one term six years
and
um i think duterte is trying to find a
loophole in the constitution where
he could still
stay as president by having a proxy
candidate take his place and he
running as vice president and when that
happens if his proxy candidate wins that
candidate might be willing to step aside
and he takes the place as president so
we're seeing that scenario that's one
scenario
and
um
we don't know how it's going to turn out
because there is something about
philippine politics that becomes messy
and unpredictable
and
we're all on our toes we're holding our
breath we don't know how things will be
the filing of the candidacy will be
around the first week of october and
it's only then that we can have a better
picture of who the candidates will be
and what the chances are
i want to ask you about how much
popularity
robert roberto duterte has in the
country how much of this is resonating
with the the actual voters themselves
because this all seems to be happening
at the top levels of the party and
somewhat excluding the wishes of the
voters
um you know there's
one
bowling station that says he still has a
relatively high
popularity vote
but the thing there is you know when you
talk to people
i i seem to get the impression well
that's just me i seem to get the
impression that they're beginning to
doubt the results of the of the surveys
um
but i think you also have to put in
the situation the pandemic the situation
of the pandemic because for the past two
years clearly the government hasn't been
able to do anything about it and
recently there's a story there's a big
controversy um a base it's a corruption
scandal actually that involves a very
dubious company run by one of duterte's
former economic advisors so um
you know people are beginning to wonder
if he was really up to it if he really
knew what he was doing
and that basically
what he was trying to do in the southern
philippines in this in the city that he
was mayor um for 20 years
isn't working now i mean this is not
part of his template um
so there's the pandemic it's not working
and people are suffering people are you
know
uh hungry
losing their jobs and i think that's
going to play well into what might
happen next year
what qualities do you think manny
pacquiao needs to be able to demonstrate
before then to be able to run
effectively against rodrigo duterte
uh
knowledge of governance it's as simple
as that and intelligence too i mean he
was not exactly an exemplary senator
you've seen videos of him being poached
by his staff
on what he has to say when there's a
debate on the floor
so
i mean
the problem with philippine politics is
that it's also become like a popularity
contest so in that case you know he
could win easily because of that because
he's an icon he's a boxing champion
um but really when it comes to the
nitty-gritty of running a country
i can't say he knows the ropes yeah
crusader yeah we appreciate your time
man thank you very much indeed
thank you